The act of eating,
especially if you're hungry,
especially if you're starving,
produces a rapid spiritual
transformation,
right?
I mean,
some of you,
this is worth knowing.
You probably have a crabby partner or
child because everyone does and one
thing you might try is that if they get
erratic during the day and you know,
get all volatile about nothing at all,
it's given them something to eat.
Really.
I'll tell you,
a man needs this souls.
If I do this with my clinical clients
all the time,
it's like they say,
well,
I fly off the handle at the littlest
things.
It's like,
okay,
yeah,
I'll just try this for a week.
When when you're crabby and
unreasonable,
eat a piece of cheese or eat a peanut
butter sandwich,
eat something that's high protein,
high fat,
and then just wait 10 minutes and see if
you're sane and you'll find out that
you're saying after you eat so often
that you just can't believe how crazy
you are when you're hungry.
Here's.
It's really absolutely bloody
remarkable.
So I'm telling you,
try this.
It'll,
it'll,
it'll.
If especially if you don't eat
breakfast,
this will change your life.